greetings and salutations as i've come
to say quite often
i would like to welcome you to a special
edition of down the middle uh today we
celebrate the one year anniversary of
the show uh by getting back to
california haven't been been here since
and visiting with our very first guest
jeffrey gundlach the founder of double
line i can't be any more pleased to be
here with you today
in your home i can't believe it's been a
year
um yeah i remember recording it i think
it was in july it was in late july july
31st as hot as dickens it was really hot
it's like 105 degrees
it was weirdly it's unusually warm day
to day well every time i come from texas
i bring the weather with me so i do my
best
so
well back then covid was raging
yeah and now covet is raging
ish
um it's well hospitalizations or
whatever they are two-thirds of what
they were at their peak but they're
still there
tell me about how covet has has changed
you as a person because we've all been
transformed by this in some way shape or
form i've spent a lot more time with my
children than i would have
otherwise and they've learned how to
exist around mom always writing but and
it's been great but kovitz changed all
of us in some way how has it changed you
um i'm probably reading more than i used
to
i've got uh a lot it's weird it's
actually working
seems to be
in some ways an increase in productivity
working from home
especially in southern california where
you can have you know
some people have over a two-hour
round-trip commute
when you think about that that's one day
of the week
actually times five is ten hours right
so it's basically one working day that's
stolen from you
and and i eat lunch in about three
minutes at
all if you go out i
never really went out much for lunch but
when i did you know it takes like 45
minutes two hours so there's another
hour
that's going away but i started reading
um
1984 the orwell the george orwell book
now
start reading it yeah and it's very
difficult i it's it's it's just too
close to the bone what you're reading
um i can only read like a couple of
chapters and then it's like i just i
just got to take a shower or something
it's just so it's just so brutal
brutally predictive
he wrote that book in 1948
so he predicted that was going to happen
pretty quickly
and it did happen fairly quickly but
i was pretty accurate i also reread
looking backward the air bellamy edward
bellamy book that was actually one of
the biggest best sellers of the second
half of the 19th century and that was
predictive too
of the future it was predictive of a
utopian society where the government
controlled everything
so that's kind of it's kind of uh maybe
that inspired orwell who knows
but it's it's interesting i i typically
don't read fiction ever
because i just i feel like i could make
it up myself
but these are these aren't really
exactly fiction books they're more of uh
you know pre-history prediction books
so
what what has our government done right
what's our government done wrong
um
as it pertains to covet because that
could be a pretty broad question
we'll get there later i promise
um
well i think uh
so far
what may be right because we don't know
what the long-term consequences of
vaccines are going to be
but clearly what president trump did
when everybody laughed at him
criticized him for doing operation warp
speed i said it was reckless said it was
impossible that we could get them rolled
out now if you give big pharma enough
incentive a lot of things can happen i
kind of notice
that uh big pharma uh has a real
i mean they have a real jackpot on their
hands here's if you need boosters every
six months
i mean the profits are unbelievable i
saw statistics that if you take ten of
these big pharma companies that the
heads of them have made billions and
billions of dollars personally
so i think the vaccine rollout
has to be viewed at least so far as
possible it turns out that it was
reckless to do it because of
side effects or long-term problems then
maybe people will rethink that but that
was right
um
i think the
the initial
uh
approach to distancing and barrier doing
i thought that was foolish i thought it
was it was fairly clear that these types
of things
are not going to be contacted from
surfaces but rather through the air
and went to a lot of pains
to to put up we originally have
plexiglass makers i know we bought a
whole regime of that stuff for the
office i don't know if it's up i've been
in the office
for a few months now i've probably been
there about six times since we did work
from home
so uh you know it's you can't really
criticize who knew exactly but it was
one of these things where we kind of
went understandably overboard
in precautions
um
i think i think the outdoor stuff was
was wrong
yeah i don't i i can't tell you yeah how
the the rest of the country viewed
outdoor dining in los angeles being
outlawed i just i had to read that
headline over and over and over again
you want to talk about something that
was done wrong it has to do with a lot
of things on the local level like there
was a sort of mini scandal
where there was this restaurant owner
who was built put all this money into
building outdoor dining and you remember
they actually they actually put a ban on
outdoor dining
yes yes
and so she was livid because
there was a movie production company
that right next to her outdoor dining
patio sent up set up a big catering tent
for some sort of tv or movie shooting so
it reveals
it reveals the way
you know local decisions are made which
has a lot to do with who you know and
cronyism
and uh you get to see kind of the the
dark side you know it's like gavin
newsom going the french laundry when he
had like you can't go to restaurant
owner it was nancy pelosi getting her
hair done when nobody else could
you know all that stuff
i think was done wrong
but it's not because of covid it's
because that kind of stuff is always
going on sure it just gets revealed
so
that
that's kind of what i think i think what
the government did
with regards to
spending uh blindly
obviously had a very substantial
fraction that was corruption uh that was
wasted california admits that tens of
billions of dollars are unaccounted for
and you know just kind of gone amazing
so there was a lot of arbitrary stuff
but uh that's kind of that's kind of
where it always works so
yeah i think
the biggest mistake relative to kovid
and i know this is a politically
sensitive topic but i think the the
southern border allowing in
over 2 million people illegally and
almost almost like
with open arms welcoming them in
illegally and obviously some of them
have coveted
that obviously wasn't a very good idea
but the whole treatment of that issue
has been
frustrating
and
disturbing
yeah
so
i don't think that was a good idea
but you know there's there's a whole
bunch of things uh
you know the first day i think buying
shut down the pipeline
which cost
jobs you know tens of thousands of jobs
and you know the price of energy went up
massively
not
solely to that but obviously in part
due to that so we have we have the
inflation uh
we have a
war
let's hold off on the war but let's
focus on inflation because uh
if you recall both of us
we had modest means when we were growing
up
and um you know i look at the effect of
the necessities of life
and
you talk about uh
consequences because i won't call them
unintended at this point but when you
talk about rental inflation and home
price inflation and how that's affected
not even low-income
americans because low-income americans
are in many ways covered but how it's
affected the middle income earners
in this country
i i think we haven't even gotten to
chapter you know halfway through the
book on on the uh
shelter inflation
because my theory is that once the
uh eviction moratorium ends
i think you are going to see a lot of
evictions
a lot of people just
aren't going to pay their back rent
and i i think they're going to get
evicted or else just say hey who even
cares
i've been living rent free for a year
and a half
and
what the hell i'm not going to pay that
back i'll just i'll just go across the
street
well i've got news for you
rents are going to go way up
i think because
if your property operator you're going
to say
there's a chance that we go back into a
moratorium right uh on evictions and if
that's the case i've got to you know
price that in
to my uh well there's something to be
said for the rule of law
yeah i mean say well if i'm charging 100
in rent i think there's a
i don't know
it'll vary by assessment but i think
there's going to be a 25 chance
that i could lose another year of rent
so i'm going to raise my rents at 10 or
20 30
just in case and uh obviously there's a
leading indicator of rent is home prices
and home prices are up 23 year-over-year
astounding i'm not sure that's exactly
the statistics most almost all the
statistics that we look at
in the post lockdown
after the advent of lockdown are kind of
skewed by mixed shifts and
all kinds of bulges and and
high-end housing has certainly been in
the lead
of home price appreciation it's not the
mix has shifted there's been a lot more
activity at the middle and upper middle
end
so there's a little bit of a
of murkiness in the numbers but 23 and
one thing that's not murky is there are
plenty of metropolitan statistical areas
that are up
clearly 20 30 and even 40 percent well
just but in the state we're in right now
since 1850 you've never had a net
contraction in your population and yet
you did in 2020 and let me tell you i i
know they're in boise idaho i know for a
fact they're in texas they're all over
texas well i i can i can tell you all
about it i i've traveled to many states
looking for property because frankly i'm
bullish and have been bullish for the
past couple of years
on certain types of of real estate
residential real estate and not in the
areas that are hot like austin and
nashville you mentioned boise i'm
looking for the places that are much
cheaper because they don't have this
kind of hurting mentality so i looked at
property in
new mexico arizona wyoming
colorado idaho and then ultimately ended
up buying a property in alabama of all
places
you had to keep going east well that was
due the fact that my brother-in-law uh
lives in alabama and he found this
property it was never officially listed
and so i thought it was really really
cheap but
yeah i mean everywhere you go
all you hear is
heard i think it's turned but there was
no supply
and there was tremendous demand and so i
was actually looking in wyoming colorado
i had this idea of a ranch which i
soured on
uh after a couple of months of looking
at it because they're too remote and
there's too hard to take care of sure um
but they were selling like crazy
i would call up i could call call up a
guy who had a listing
and he'd say you know usually if you
call them up you call a real estate
agent they're back to you within three
minutes you know they got they got a
fish on the hook right
and they want to reel them in but uh
i didn't get called back for like a day
two days from israel and they all said
exactly the same thing that is i thought
last year was a good year this year is
multiples
gangbusters
i i think i have never worked so hard in
my life
and the properties that were good
another reason i soured on the ranch
concept the ones that were good where
they actually had good improvements
that's actually a problem
they were every i would call up and
they'd say it's under contract
and it was listed like two days earlier
under contract under contract
and so yeah it's clear that those prices
exploded i have a house in buffalo new
york
and i bought it in november of 2017.
and boy that was good timing i didn't
buy that as an investment but
um
i i think it's probably worth more than
double
what i paid for it my nephew lives there
in the suburbs
and he told me that three years ago he
would have been very happy to sell his
house for 125 000
and he thinks he's going to get close to
300 000.
so
speak to me about how this episode
therefore is going to impact income
inequality in america
um
it has changed income inequality in a
way that has greatly enriched the uber
rich
i think uh you look at what's happened
to like amazon's
uh world
you know and facebook and twitter and
all that sort of stuff
um
and i i think it it might have
temporarily helped out the very very low
end
but i think we just continue to hollow
out the middle
i think money money giveaways have
historical precedent
and basically what happens when you get
deeper into the money giveaways
is uh there there's so much shortages
which are obviously apparent today and
there's so much
inflation at certain places
that what happens is that the people who
were at the lower end prior to the money
giveaways actually get into abject
poverty that happened that's happened
pretty much every time well that's
that's the thing right and the ones that
really do well are those that are close
to the levers of money printing
they become
they make sure they get an extra dose
one way or another either through an
extra check or under the table or
through the economic consequences so but
you know that that's what ended up
causing ultimately the french revolution
well i was going to say i mean this is
i'm jumping
the gun here in terms of coming to
conclusions but how does this i mean
what does this imply for the future of
of the united states
i mean
and how do we turn off
the spigot how do we unplug people we've
been covering
their major expenses for since april of
2020 with the passage of the cares act
we've got a tiger by the tail
and
uh
initially people thought well we had no
option
because we were going to get mauled by
the tiger and now we've got tell your
body tells a funny expression i don't
think it's really going to stop you from
being mauled because it gives you these
the sense that you're you're temporarily
safe
and uh
it's going to be interesting once we let
go of can we let go of the tail
because it's obvious that we had
momentous you know
shifts
based upon these policies and getting
out of them will not be smooth
it will have to be shifts we already
talked briefly about
rent inflation which of course means
that inflation broadly
is is either presently understated or is
about to be uh either revealed or
continues to be understated that owner's
equivalent rent
really sticks out because that's a very
big component and it's not transitory
it's never transitory of the cpi it's a
big component of cpi and i i don't i
don't uh know what the most recent data
point was but it's been around two two
and a half percent year over year
housing prices are up 23
and rents are up more than two point
something percent and they're about to
go a lot higher if you used and this is
overly simplistic but it's telling if
you use 23 percent it's the shelter
component of cpi
cpi would be over 11 on the headline
right now
and uh it would be way higher on the
core because the shelter is also
involved there
and so uh there's going to be those
types of consequences and and people are
feeling that i mean that that's people's
reality today in many cases i mean if
whether you're talking about apartment
rates or single-family rentals you know
when they're turning these new leases
they're seeing just huge numbers there's
huge increases on turning leases i i
think it's already running
you know it's all depend upon specific
circumstance but still it's already
running double-digit so um and the
campbell's soup index which is really a
funny index it's good because it goes
back to the 1800s when you started
campbell's soup and it's just what's the
price of cost what's the cost of one can
of tomato soup
uh i i don't know what flavor they use
but i think they're all the same price i
don't even know but
um campbell's soup index is obviously a
parabola going back to
the inception but the most recent data
point was uh a year ago and it was 85
cents a can
today it's a dollar
so there you go i've also have other
anecdotal evidence that this is not
transitory and that has to do with the
cost of hiring
workers and i'm talking about the pool
guy
gardener somebody to come over and i i
had a a
water problem one of the bathrooms i had
to try to get a guy to come over and
do some touch-up
and he said he's done a lot of work for
me so he's he's
gave me a
an audience even and he said i have
three years of work
and i mentioned going around all these
different places everywhere i went
and i'm sure this is everyone can verify
this
everywhere people say i can't get
workers
you know i'm competing with the
government
you see a signs i saw a sign an in-n-out
burger yesterday now hiring 18 an hour i
went to you go to places uh there's a
great hot dog chain in buffalo it's
called ted's hot dogs it was founded
like in 1928 yep and they've expanded
and they've got i don't even know how
many locations now probably a dozen and
we went to the one we always go to
and there's a sign that says a location
closed
can't get worse workers one and then
they have a list and another one
the about half of them are closed the
other ones have workers and they're open
11 a.m to 4 p.m because that's all they
can hire now hiring all locations all
shifts part-time full-time yep it
doesn't matter i i'll add your anecdotes
it doesn't matter what caliber of hotel
you're checking into they're telling you
at check-in that there's no there's no
cleaning service
really
i i i woke up this morning here in santa
monica and i made my bed i went to this
high-end restaurant i'm friends with the
owner
and
i i couldn't believe it it used to be
that the the little rib eye was 50 bucks
now it's 80.
and i said hutch when are you uh when
are you going to put the price back down
he said i'm never putting the price back
down never has never worked yeah never's
a long time
and uh
so there's all kinds of that that stuff
going on
so um
let's go back to
prior to the pandemic let's go back to
and jay powell is something of a rookie
um
credit spreads start to
widen after the debt of general electric
is downgraded yeah and they stayed up
they stayed up all the way through not
qe
they remained elevated all the way up
until
the advent of
of covid landing on american shores
and we obviously had problems in the
plumbing world trade contracted for the
full year
of
2019 that's never occurred without the
us falling into recession yeah there
were a lot of indicators that were
saying that inflation that recession was
getting more likely right um the leading
indicators turned negative before code
um that type of thing the the spread
between consumers view of the present
which was very lofty
in the future which was
which was prescient right um you know
that was that was looking uh so there
were there were signposts but what i'm
getting at is
the fed had to
uh
increasingly deploy
more and more liquidity and not call it
qe they were really careful to call it
not qe and
distinguished and it was sunday markets
froze up for example that was a real
canary in the coal mine we talked about
that at a time
you know it's like you know weird things
are starting to happen here and that a
little bit of that seems like it's
happening now well that's what i'm
getting to
so um but if you look at the aftermath
of the financial crisis
the fed was enough
on its own
quantitative easing was enough
on its own yeah you look at this
aftermath and you had to have a double
barrel build approach you had to have
the monetary
and the fiscal
both i mean if i read correctly from a
st louis fed paper
since the the since the cares act we've
injected 43.2 percent of gdp
over the span of stimulus more than the
new deal yeah
sure every time we have a recession
um going back about uh
25 years or something like that
we add some other
you know
weapon to the arsenal
and we all keep using the old ones but
we always need a new one and every time
it happens we say can you believe that
it's come to this
and and uh remember people thinking that
the the quantitative easing back in the
aftermath of the global financial crisis
that was outrageous yep
and i remember when aig 85 billion was
like wow i i just call it i just call it
the explosion of the deficit
you know last year's gdp officially
real gdp was negative two
and this year they're talking real gdp
of about six
some of which is inflation uh no that's
a real gdp but they don't have deflation
right anyway let's just say let's accept
the numbers
so for the for the time period it was
negative three and a half i think last
year if i'm remembering right now the
the point is that we're we're only up
about two percent
for 2020 and 2021 based upon the
estimates for all that money that was
spent right so we spent and it wasn't
invested mind you it was spent it was
just giving away a lot of it or else or
were corruptionated right but um
yeah i mean i i've lost track you
probably probably have the number at
your fingertips but the total uh just
the giveaways forget about anything else
was is it is it six trillion
i can't remember but let's just say it's
let's just say it's closer to seven but
yes okay close to seven well that's that
right there
is 30 percent of gdp
unbelievable and we got
for 30 of gdp
expansion of the budget deficit
we got two percent real growth
before we go to where we are today
i want to ask you a question in your
wheelhouse
um kind of brass tacks
so j powell came out with
unheard of levels of quantitative easing
i mean the fed was just buying i mean
there were days that the fed bought a
hundred billion dollars grew its balance
sheet by 100 men one day i mean i just i
remember being a spectator you know
going you got to be kidding me
did jay powell also have to bail out the
corporate bond market yes why
because uh
it was completely dysfunctional
the
the amount of sellers was overwhelming
the amount of buyers people were pulling
money
out of those types of funds
and
they
had to be liquidated
and so i'm speaking prior to covid by
the way oh
i'm speaking
when he came out march the 23rd
he grandfathered in triple b's did that
have to be done
well no it doesn't have to be done
but
it was kind of like the way that we
did things with social distancing they
aired on the side of i guess i would
call it
a twisted form of caution
and there's there was a real fear there
there was
i've got to tell you
i've lived through a lot of stuff i've
been at this almost 40 years and i've
lived through a lot of these
the
the sentiment and the panic
that was in the
credit markets
corporate credit included
was at a level that i've never seen
before
there was a
actual reporting back to me from some of
my investment teams that in certain
sectors the bid was zero
there was no bid
and there was actually moments where
there's no bid on some treasuries
that is correct
in asian trading i remember they didn't
have to do it there would have been
incredible amounts of of downgrades and
bankruptcies if they didn't
uh would that have been a bad thing no
it wouldn't have been it well
you know it's a question of short term
versus long term in the short term
i guess it was
like i guess it was a good thing
to do it
but
in the long term you you need credit
cycles to cleanse
to cycle through yeah you need credit
cycles to so so that you can get rid of
the zombies
get rid of the inefficient companies and
it doesn't happen and a lot of people
argue you know that's that's one of the
things that's fueled deflation is
excessive supply of stuff and there's
some logic to that
but
uh
you know when you give out this much
money the the
the the
the consumer's wherewithal
overcomes
you know the
disinflationary forces true so i i just
i'm just disgusted frankly and i've said
this before
i'm just disgusted that the federal
reserve is operating in
shameless
violation of federal reserve act of
1913.
the federal reserve is is mandated uh to
make policy in the public interest
that's in the very top paragraph of the
home page of the federal reserve system
in the public interest yeah that's
that's uh open to interpretation i
suppose depends on which public you're
talking about the one percent or the
rest right right so
i'm starting to see evidence of
[Music]
a little bit
triple c's that are the riskiest sectors
they're worth 80 basis points
a little bit now part of that's because
treasury rates have risen
i think a little bit a little bit
but you see i mean covenant lights now
are 90
for leveraged loans leverage loans now
are 90 of them have very little investor
protections prior to covet it was 80 so
we've kind of ramped that up i was
watching an interview a few days ago
with a private debt manager
saying that private debt
some of the private debt that's out
there which is over a trillion dollars
now is covenant light i i said what i
said i turned up the volume and i
rewound it and i said he surely did
in february of 2020 we had 10 trillion
dollars outstanding in corporate bonds
now we were tracking to get to 12
trillion by the end of 2021 based on the
run rate of
of of issuance
where are we going with this
well the one thing with the corporate
the junk bond market uh in particular
which is three trillion dollars now it's
very big and the spreads are tight i'll
say one thing in support of the the junk
bond market and that is the credit
quality of it is better than it has been
typically in the past the junk bond
market because of all the refinancings
the balance sheets are pretty strong
compared to history and also a lot of
the junk bond market has been uh
populated with some downgrades of of
investment grade true now the investment
grade market that's that was my next
question where does that leave the
investment grade market not so that's
not in such great shape yeah i use air
quotes they're they're though still i
mean the bail
the refinancing has been enormous
corporate bond market and that's that's
been that that helps but the debt itself
hasn't been whittled down oh no
certainly it's grown
it's bigger of course it's grown yeah
so you know the corporate bond market is
extremely low yielding on just an
absolute basis the entire bond market is
extremely low yield
on
just on an absolute basis the junk bond
market to no defaults today yields 4.0
the cpi and that's not adjusted for
inflation cpi is at 5.4 and that's
probably understated
so you have you have negative real rates
in the junk bond market
which is i i think that's probably a
first
negative field rates in the junk bond
market so
let's just let's just play a
hypothetical because you're reading 1984
not me you're braver than i am
we have a few things going on in
washington dc right now
yeah um
there are very few people who are paying
attention to the debt limit
at all
well they're going to pay they're going
to reason
that's i don't even i frankly don't
really pay attention to it because i
know they're going
so in 2013 ben bernanke was given a
blueprint he was given a roadmap
on
how the government could strategically
default
on fed holdings of bonds
such that
there was really no harm no foul because
you were keeping it with you in the
family
do you think that
that given
the stakes
one seat in the senate
three seats in the house of
representatives
do you not think that that one party
over another is incentivized to use this
to play serious hardball
i mean we've just spent an inordinate
amount of money in afghanistan
yeah and the government's gonna be more
in afghanistan well the government's
cash balance started off at 300 billion
dollars going into this
and then they extended the rental
eviction moratorium through
october so
all i'm saying is the cash burn rate is
higher than what it would otherwise have
been absent the extension of yet another
safety net and
afghanistan but if you're if you're
mitch mcconnell
what is your incentive to
play ball to raise the debt ceiling in
order to facilitate three and a half
trillion dollars
to expand the social safety net
by soaking the rich theoretically which
always ends up getting middle income
earners tax wise
and raising corporate taxes and buying
votes of progressives what what's your
incentive to to go along i'm just asking
a hypothetical your only incentive is
that
you're
you know to not raise the debt limit
uh by by seven trillion dollars it's
almost sacrilegious
that's what janet yellen says yeah
i know i i i'm not saying i believe that
i'm saying that's the way the
politicians think
and so that's going to get raised the
real the real question is going to be
what happens after
the midterms
because i think i think the
as a base case
it seems to me that things can change
but it's a base case because we're more
than a year out
but as a base case you're going to see a
huge loss of democratic seats in the
house of representatives i think
because one of the things that's
underneath the surface here is that
people are getting angry at the local
level they're angry at this at the
teachers unions
and the school stuff
right they're angry at the lockdowns
they're angry and and what makes them
more angry
is when the local decisions
are are made
in accordance with
largely the wishes of that local
community and then they get reversed out
of washington dc
and so
that makes people want to get rid of the
bums who are at the local level which is
the congress
the congress of men and women
and so i i think the way they express
the anger of their local decisions being
upstream to washington who reverses what
they want the consequence of that is
going to be voting out a lot of people
so we're we're not going to have
this uh
sort of 50 50 senate which they are able
to get things done reconciliating do
everything on reconciliation it seems
and they got a little bit of an
edge in the house is going to go away
the senate i i'm not sure uh because
that's that's
that's less of a local level
uh but but that's going to change
and so
i think the democratic
leadership knows that that's a serious
risk and so they're going to want to get
every possible thing done
if they can before the midterms and so
that's why they're they're sprinting as
fast as they can to get this stuff
through
but yeah
i i
i see that being
one of the biggest problems is that it's
pass it now and figure it out later so
that you can get a piggy bank
of this three and a half trillions is
the one that might be the one that
breaks the camel's back
because it's just it's just completely
like undefined and doesn't seem to have
any real purpose other than a slush fund
right
so with that in mind and we'll agree to
disagree about the debt limit um because
i think that
i i think the republicans have a real
weapon to carry them into
the midterms but we're both coming to
the same conclusion after the midterms
which brings me to my question
can the fed go it alone
let's just say that there's
let's just say that we're starting to
see rumblings in the credit market and
nothing's going to happen overnight but
we're starting to see a little bit of a
risk aversion
pop into the into the credit market so
if there's if you're talking about a
change of leadership a little bit like
the widening uh in the fall of 2018
a little bit at this point
you know and and the way that the the
damage occurs it's it's like in the
uh the sun also rises there's this thing
how did you go bankrupt bill asked you
know
and you know it's like
uh first slowly then all of them all at
once
i don't see
necessarily a fiscal bailout of the
magnitude that we've just
seen
i i don't see it repeat it if you
repeated it you would you would have uh
serious inflation problems
i mean serious inflation problems if you
repeated that
the first stimulus
was largely
pay down debt and save
because people had no clarity in the
future they're scared to death they
thought they might lose their job
the second one
had largely the same characteristic but
the third one started to get spent
because people are now starting to
factor into their
management of financial management
that this is going to continue
and if it's going to continue well then
you can spend it or if you if you've
paid down your doubt i mean one thing
that's fascinating about all of this is
when the pandemic started the things
that were most at risk and most people
were most fearful of
were like uh credit card receivables oh
yeah fearline leases and all that the
household debt cycle the credit cycle
but but household finances uh in terms
of delinquencies on credit cards they've
never been lower
right so if you took this stuff away
it would have
it would have all kinds of negative you
know gdp type of economic consequences
just to start with
your your deficit would be smaller and
that would become it would turn the
positive in gdp into a negative in the
delta for gdp
uh
so yeah like i said got tiger by the
tail
and
people made this analogy and it is
almost like
eerie the similarity between well turned
out getting out of afghanistan wasn't
wasn't so easy after all now maybe we
didn't do it in an optimal way so you
could make the argument it didn't have
to be as messy as it is but it's sort of
like getting out of this isn't going to
be easy and so strange how they're
contemporaneous
well so
let's shift gears for a second to what's
happening on the ground
in the economy
when you start to see that that car
sales on a unit basis are going to
decline for a fourth sequential month
half a million units four months in a
row
i mean car lots are not empty there are
cars it's and and retail sales look like
they're slowing the home market looks
like
it's turning it's just too expensive now
for most people if you took if you took
the stimulus away the housing market
would have serious problems so do so
people talk a lot about the fiscal cliff
but very few people are talking about
the demand cliff right the the thing is
you mentioned the housing market back in
april which i think was the
it was the the
there was yep there was nothing for sale
there were regions where there were
three times as many real estate agents
as there were listings
which sounds bad if you're a real estate
agent
and inventories you know got down to the
lowest ever they're still really low
right but they're rising mm-hmm i was in
buffalo
i wasn't
wary of these types of anecdotal things
being extrapolated but i think this one
it's valid i was in buffalo in april and
i did not see a single for sale sign
there wasn't one
there were some sold signs but there
were no for sale signs i was back there
in july
and there were a lot of signs
because the prices are high compared to
what people think about right and you
know you look at the affordability
indices
and they're they're
pretty close to
the levels that some of the highest
levels in terms of lack of affordability
right
then you've seen and you know the the
old adage which has some truth to it is
the cure for high prices is highlighted
prices you know and you're getting
pushback the the surveys that say is
this a good time to buy a house or a car
uh it's at sort of one of the worst
levels ever did at a 40 40 or low no
it's not a good time yep
and that's how people feel so
um
yeah i think the housing mark is sort of
peaked out
it's at a high level
i'm not so sure it has to decline as
long as interest rates see you you said
you talked about you know is can the fed
go it alone and all this stuff can we do
one more of these things
the real question is will when
and if ever will the fed
allow the free market
to set interest rates
because that doesn't seem to be
happening right now i i can't imagine
why somebody would want to buy a junk
bond with a yield below the inflation
rate and that's obviously predicated on
the fed being at zero
for forever for who knows as far as the
eye can see
and i think they've been
stealthily doing yield curve control
it seems that they've been extending the
maturities of the quantitative easing so
uh
it looks to me like we had the 30-year
treasury bond got up to two and a half
yield
back in march
and now it seems to
not want to go above two yeah it's hit a
ceiling it'll go it'll go above two for
five minutes intraday and it'll close at
198.
and you don't believe in coincidences
yeah and and
it's about 187 i think right now
and it seems like they're trying to cap
it around two percent
and
the one thing that's
a funny conclusion of all of this
is that as
incredibly high as the stock market is
on a historical valuation basis using pe
or dr schiller's cape ratio
price to book whatever have you
it's actually below average valuation
versus treasury bonds
shocking as that is that one of the
highest ps of all time and it's actually
below average on a relative comparison
of treasury bonds and so that the fed is
by doing that yield perfect roll it's
another tiger by the tail we have
historical precedent for yield curve
control
it's from the late 40s into the mid 50s
and
coincidentally perhaps the interest rate
levels and the inflation level where
they set you know in the 40s when they
were doing it was kind of the same as
it was before we started our yield curve
control knob
you had short rates about 3 8.
you had you know long rates around two
that's kind of where we are so we're
doing the same thing so what happened
that inflation started to go up
uh and we had negative real yields back
in in the 40s and 50s
and they kept doing the yield curve
control people said well this
inflation's not good it's going to be
transitory and there were some inflation
bumps in there and when they stopped at
yield curve control they let go of the
tiger his tail
well that started a 30 nearly 30-year
bear market that took rates from two
percent to on some vehicles 20 but on
long rates you know 14 or 15 percent
and so
that's kind of the setup that we have
right now
is that we're we're set up for that i
will will they control for eight years
maybe
maybe uh and but so at some point
you're going to have the in the
collision
of all this debt and perhaps
a market that won't accept these low
interest rates
and that's the thing people say well
we don't have to worry about the debt
because japan has more debt to gdp than
we do and they don't have any well
that's because their rate is at zero
if you have rates of zero you can have
infinite debt right which our
policymakers seem to have finally
figured out the the the math of that
zero times
you know anything 100 trillion is zero
right
and so it looks fine
and and then i was asked a question in
an interview i did uh recently someone
talked about you know modern monetary
theory who cares about debt to gdp as
long as doesn't as long as your policies
aren't causing inflation
what's wrong with that logic this fellow
asked me and i said um we have inflation
we have inflation right
it's not like we don't have inflation
and the fed started out
basically taking cover underneath the
words temporary and transitory
and it seemed like temporary transitory
meant the second quarter into like june
so it was going to be a couple three
months they were waiting for those base
effects right the base effects
but we don't hear much about base
effects anymore well it's because there
aren't any anymore uh we're already
getting into a comparison of of of
higher numbers
right and so then then
transitory turned into felt like
six to eight months so they sort of
doubled one of the fed district
presidents defined it that way maybe
nine to 12 months i think now we're
talking nine to twelve
and i think it's going to end up going
to like 12 to 18
because
most people we have a fairly simplistic
inflation model that's been
surprisingly accurate for its simplicity
we knew that inflation was going to go
above a four handle
and
a lot of that had to do with the price
of energy going up and expectations of
shelter going up yep
we didn't which is fed data
we didn't talk about headline cpi we did
see in our model 5 handle
but
now the model continues to believe that
we're going to have a five handle on
year-over-year cpi headline
every month except maybe year-end where
we think it's a coin toss whether it
starts with a four four or five
so that that's going to be about eight
nine months of of transitory
so-called
and so uh we'll we'll see but
inflation hasn't been transitory and it
doesn't appear that it's going to be so
you've talked a lot about inflation you
haven't talked any about stagflation
which it's starting to feel like i don't
i mean it feels this feels a lot
like jimmy carter uh and a lot of people
started to use that metaphor i think i
was the first one because
we now have what appears to be a
potential hostage crisis
we have what looks like
elevated inflation that's not going away
right
and without
forever stimulus we're going to have
a downturn in economics uh economic uh
activity right that's why it's it's
there's a demand cliff you know
everybody's keeps has been basically
saying we've got this this pig in the
python which is the stimulus and
lockdowns but it's all going to go back
to the same size python
uh
but nobody can 20 20. nobody can tell
you how though right in 2022. so
everybody expects you know we had to
jump the the the effect of the stimulus
propping up gdp
to a big number in the first quarter and
then it's a little lower in the second
quarter and supposedly lower in the
third and fourth and that's supposed to
magically just be three percent real
growth
and perpendicular to i
i just think it's almost mathematically
impossible that you could
even ramp
down the stimulus
and not have negative economic growth
we're already seeing it i mean
i've been i've been researching this
term fiscal thrust because now the
thrust is going backwards yes and you're
seeing red bars instead of where you saw
green bars and i mean it's a
it's a real depressant in terms of if
it's not replaced and again i just
it's it's it's factored into the economy
and the type of stimulus they're
discussing is what spread out over eight
or ten years
that's not money injected into checking
accounts it's a different kind of
stimulus it's even being contemplated
and then one of the effects of of the
lockdowns and the inflation clearly has
been
especially around here
a rampant increase in homelessness
uh i don't know if you drove downtown
but you won't recognize it there's
there's tents everywhere
there's a there's a federal property
that's in a very nice area it's off of
wilshire boulevard and san vicente
and because it's federal property it's
there's tents all over it and i think
most of them are our veterans
we've got a similar situation in austin
and the homelessness is through the roof
and therefore and this is prior to the
rental eviction moratorium that's right
running out right
and crime
is just off the charts
it's it's hard to believe that they've
made it legal
to steal from a store 950 worth of
merchandise
here
you will not be prosecuted for stealing
from a store you've seen the videos of
people just crazily going in filling up
a garbage bag and riding their bicycle
out of the store
and nobody stops them
so yeah you have a similar sensation in
new york right now we have modern
monetary theory in these urban areas
going on right now because you can you
can hit 10 stores a day for 900 bucks a
pop that's nine thousand dollars if you
sell it at pennies on the dollar you're
making a thousand dollars a day tax free
and there are businesses
that were set up for
uh
well-meaning purposes
where there's they're selling clothing
that's never been used that has tags on
them
like like it's supposed to be like a
second-hand store so it's you know like
a salvation army finance actually
for-profit these are actually for-profit
stores
and they no questions asked
so you go in you drop off your garbage
bag full of stuff you just pilfered an
hour ago and you're basically just just
fencing it
so you know who cares if you get 10 or
20 cents on the dollar
if you're if you're able to do thousands
of dollars a day and so these
shopkeepers are shutting down
and you there's off
crime in los angeles is just off the
charts my security company has
recommended and we've implemented all
kinds of things you never would have
thought you would do
you know like radar so you're surveying
away from your property because there's
there's so many people that are casing
houses
uh crime is way way up and that's that's
not a coincidence all these things are
interrelated
so
if i hear you and i've seen similar
similar
feeling in a similar scenario in new
york i've been there five
been in new york in times two years well
it misses you
but um
but but there there's
there's an ancillary market here that
it's nobody's really talking about
and that's offices
the ecosystem surrounding
offices and metro areas has died
the small businesses the the lunch
places oh that type of thing yes oh yes
these closures are uh very high
and you know they're not going to reopen
so
we've we've definitely taken out that's
that's that's a manifestation that's
that's that's part of the hollowing out
of the middle
these were these small businesses these
are small business owners exactly and
now
with money money printing what's
happening to them
they're going down the economic ladder
they're now in in sort of a
you know
a receiving class so they're just
they're at the mercy
of these governmental programs
so
with this most recent bout of of delta
that is obviously passing um we've seen
office occupancy
come back down we're seeing
the world bank that was the latest one
headline to cross we're seeing all kinds
of companies postponing
coming back into the office we're
uh
you know contemplating what to do at
double line
several months ago
uh maybe three months ago it looked like
uh based on the trends that you know
after labor day
that was kind of a common theme and
i'm wondering we have to do it
voluntarily so it's voluntary for the
people
i i think the percentage that are going
to volunteer to do it is way down from
where it would have been three months
ago so i think it's pretty clear that
like we had this management retreat uh
over the over the last few days
sort of it was established in
anticipation of back to work yep and
there are
and it was
it was a good event i mean it's up in
montecito it's on the ocean
the weather was perfect
you know good food you know
there were there were not
not an insignificant number of people
that said i'm not doing i'll do it
virtually
and i mean that's that was like a paid
vacation
so
what does this imply for office
properties
there's a lot of big office properties
and there's a lot of big multi-family
towers that have been raised to support
robust
and growing urban centers and full
office buildings
but is it possible that we're going to
learn how to partially work from home
for a while oh i think it's i think it's
more than a while i i think in some
departments for certain functions
certainly it's it's already
not in the present moment it's already
permanent
doesn't that imply that we've got too
many offices yes it does but
think about it
like
even before any of this happened years
before this happened there were plenty
of investment management firms that were
outsourcing you know nav calculations
back office to lower cost areas
and that's one of the ways austin got
going
was that type of stuff
and certainly i t people
i think it people are more productive
certainly and lose almost nothing in a
work from home situation it might be
literally nothing right
if you're talking about the commuting
then they're gaining we're getting back
that two and a half hours a day no to i
don't begrudge these people if they want
to take an hour
of that two and a half hours of savings
and you know
uh go for a walk
that's okay with me we're still getting
we're still getting that negativity
but there's there's every reason for
people like that
to continue work from home and
our operational group there's there's
just not a glitch
because they're basically working
through systems anyway right the whole
thing is systematized the the thing that
you that that that is the the bugaboo
about the the the work from home
is we've hired
probably two dozen people
since we started working from home
i haven't met them right i met one of
them
at our manager conference because he's a
manager
it's only for managed people manage
people
and and the others you know i
interviewed a couple
virtually i did meet with one in buffalo
because uh at the time
uh coveted was way way right right he
flew to buffalo from new york city
um but that's and that's why i met i've
got two of the 24 and it's very
difficult to
uh train people on you know the
processes the culture the culture i mean
that's something that they can't be yeah
to give them further opportunity it's
much more helpful
at the office and of course
collaboration
when it comes to
spontaneous collaboration which
in in investing money across many asset
classes and across the world
many teams spontaneous communication and
creativity is
valuable very very right
i'll read something i'll be at my
trading desk and i'll read something
and i'll just walk over to uh to you
know the bank loan group and i say hey
right and so we can talk about it that
way and sure you can schedule a call on
teams or zoom it's not the same no it's
not it's not the same
i think law firms have
have realized that and they're they're
almost forcing in in some ways the you
know their their their employee base is
to come back even if it's with protocol
or mass or whatever but it's still um
yeah we have we've we've the same
meetings i we have more meetings now
because
you have to replace
the the spot name and you do that by
setting up um i would almost say a
redundant number of meetings
so that you know there is that chance
you schedule some time where somebody
might have something spontaneous that
they thought to bring to the party we
didn't used to have
an executive committee meeting five days
a week
we we had one like every two to every
two weeks right now we have one we have
one pretty much every single day and you
know obviously since that's a redundant
number of meetings sometimes they're 10
minutes but then sometimes we'll get
like an hour
we have investment committee meetings
and macro meetings which we used to do
spontaneously
in a certain sense and then we would
have a formal meeting you know uh once a
week
and then other
for certain other sub-sectors you know a
really
detailed thing once a month
now it's four days a week
the same thing and and the macro meeting
which i just did today
is almost always two hours
it's really long
it's because we go we have to go through
on a systematic basis all this stuff our
our fixed income s allocation meeting is
starting to get to starting to push
three hours
because we only do that once a month and
that's it's it's painful to be up to be
on team sure for for three hours and of
course
another negative of the work from home
in the teams or zoom sort of situation
is people can just turn off their camera
and go water the lawn if they feel like
it true i i started a pretty funny
technique
uh i i stumbled across it
by accident
and that is i
one time i i forgot to uh hit the
disconnect button
and so i went back
and
booted it back up like 20 minutes later
and there's still a bunch of faces there
which means they weren't really in the
meeting right exactly they didn't they
weren't because they didn't know what
ended right wow which is a really good
way of kind of stealthily understanding
who's contributing that's right you know
first of all they don't say anything you
know there's people that just don't say
anything we talked about this last time
that it was a good way of identifying
yeah and
and actually yeah and we've had uh we've
had some changes
as a consequence of this well so so
speak about an outgrowth of that because
not a lot of people are talking about
massive investment that a lot of
companies have made
in
an accelerating automation
i mean this pandemic is
again you learned
which of your employees were productive
which weren't and you also learned
well gee i can i don't actually need a
human being to do this after all yes
yeah
and and separately
will business travel budgets ever go
back to where they were never
there's there's no way it it's
when i think back of what we used to do
in the 80s
dating myself and
you know the 90s
it was insane the stuff that we would do
in terms of business travel i
countless times
flew
to
say i remember it's
this is
always top of mind for some reason to
minneapolis for one meeting
fly to minneapolis
me and the meeting is like 20 minutes
and that was just the way the business
worked it was too they would you would
get you would get a call
on it would happen it was frequent you
get a call on like a thursday
and we we
we have a committee meeting we need we
want you to present
uh in a week yep
it happened all the time
but you had to check over there so you
blow a whole day
flying to minneapolis
then you got your meeting and you fly
back that's two days
that are gone
and
we used to have so many people visiting
the office
and i don't think
even half of them are going to do that
anymore
because
it it it doesn't seem that the
cost-benefit analysis is is is nuttily
uh opposed
to continuing that activity and so you
can definitely do that stuff uh and so
it'll never come back
we saved
it's interesting how much money you save
well that's the thing that's my point is
once you automate once you save money on
on business and travel i mean once you
see that go straight to the bottom line
you're never turning those switches back
on at our management conference we had
i don't know 75 people there or
something like this
and
we it was not low budget it was like
paid vacation
essentially a resort in one of the best
locations in the world
and it wasn't cheap i'll tell you that i
was shocked at how high the hotel room
so i talk about inflation i was shocked
i mean it was
probably triple what i expected it was
unbelievable
and yet with all of that
it was less than one month's cost of
business travel
in pre pandemic wow there's less than a
month
that is perspective
that's amazing i i could not believe how
high the rooms were but it didn't matter
uh it was it was it was basically if
it's sporadic
right and and we we have just tremendous
savings on the travel and
i don't i don't think people
i don't think people really are all that
anxious to
to fly across the country for two
meetings
when they when there
is some efficiencies without it and
yeah i i finally did have a client come
uh
and uh we went out to dinner this was
this was like three weeks ago now it was
the first time that it happened since
since the pandemic started
well it must have been a good dinner
it was it was good
this this fella he's kind of a friend of
mine i call him a client but we've known
each other for
20 years
and so
uh we just like to share reviews and
stuff but it it felt weird it was like
you know you sort of forget how to order
sure
um
let's let's look ahead let's look at
who's at the table going forward janet
yellen has publicly endorsed
jay powell to be renominated yeah it's
one big happy family
is she the right person for her job is
he the right person for his job is joe
biden the right person for his job
i think i think powell
has
found
kind of his groove to a certain extent
fed governors i mean they always in the
end they always seem to do the same
thing as their predecessors did i don't
really see a lot of change
janet yellen i i think is as treasury
secretary i i just i just don't see it i
don't i don't see the the skill set
there
would she be able to do a not qe would
she be able to handle a financial
plumbing she's just she's just gonna
push the go button
you could you could have you could just
have a computer
you just say yes
you just go along
you know
that's it and then you know
i don't know the pres the presidency
ages people really quickly biden already
looks substantially older than he did
last november
my my my theory is that it speeds up
your aging clock by a factor of about
four so in four years they age about 16
years maybe it's three maybe age 12
years but if that's the case spine has
already aged a couple of years
and you know
it uh
it's not it's it'll it it
doesn't look good i mean it looks like
i i should put this way i wish i had
i don't want to get political but i wish
i had a president that didn't have to
read crypt notes at press conferences
that's not a big ask i like that you
tweeted that out it's just not a big ass
right
so
um
let's not make it political but let's
take the example of how afghanistan
has been handled
and
looking back again this is prior to the
pandemic
growth in china had slowed to a 30-year
low
not anymore
how has the u.s the u.s stimulus has
been great for china okay so you know
the stories about container shipping
that they've gotten to the point where
they just ship them back empty
well we've been dead i mean from here
from from long beach from from los
angeles they've dead headed back all
these containers and now
china's sitting on all these empty
containers
doesn't that put them in the cat bird
seat when they report import export
prices which are through the roof
does i think that's uh i'm told that
that's a pretty clean measure of
inflation a lot cleaner than cpi shares
with its adjustments does that include
the cost of shipping it
do they just import prices include the
cost of shipping it i don't know i i
actually have no idea i think it does
but i don't think it does no i think it
doesn't that means no i know people in
in in the industrial world and that's a
whole separate cost center even though i
think it's free prices year over year
are up 37
that doesn't include i think the cost of
shipping it
it's just unbelievable the the the ppi
has gone up on average a percent a month
this year i mean that's that's that's
carteresque
so anyway i i took you off your your
candles well but however no you didn't
because
the
our response pandemic has
kind of pulled china out of its morass
right now its industrial sectors is
leading
um
was chinese gdp for 2020. i think it was
i think it was like some crazy number
like it was
i think there were borders in there that
were double-digit mm-hmm
there were
you know so
it's it's the strangest thing because
it's that
the economic uh
winner
in the
in the pandemic is
potentially the country
maybe
right you know
whether or not well i doubt that
but we do know that they knew it existed
for
six to eight weeks before they signed
the trade the trade agreement so
but but more to the point go back to
afghanistan for a minute
if you're xi jinping and you're watching
how this is playing out
and you've got your eyes on taiwan or
not
you have to be in the right position or
how do you approach
your relationship with the united states
given that two years ago you were back
footed and now you're not
you're thinking about china
well i mean china sent their people over
uh
to alaska
and you were supposed to have a
five-minute
uh prepared thing
and then you were going to have a
dialogue
and the chinese official came in and i
think he went for way more than five
minutes
and all he did is say who the heck are
you to lecture us
on human rights where i can't pick up a
newspaper turn on the tv
and hear and not hear about
all of the human rights abuses in the
united states
you know with all of your all of your
racism and all of your
you know white supremacy and all of your
uh you know other stuff
interesting point
and russia pulled the same thing
and it's obvious to me
that
we we cannot possibly defend taiwan i
can't see how it could possibly that was
my question i don't think it's possible
first of all we don't have any money
we don't we don't have any we haven't
built our productive capacity at all
with this gdp is a lot has a lot to do
with buying chinese goods through amazon
sure
and financializing the country
right how is that gdp when you take all
of this seventy percent of of gdp
supposedly is consumption
if it's just chinese goods that
consumption is bogus gdp right
and the other the other effort has gone
into financialization as opposed to
productive ends yes
so i don't see any way
the other problem that we're gonna we're
having and again all these things are
interconnected
there's there's going to be
a
frightening fall off
in
uh enlistments in the military
i'm convinced people just aren't going
to want to enlist because the way
that the military has chosen to start
you know their education programs and
all this stuff i again another anecdote
i know this guy really well who's from
military family uncle's father right
grandma
and he was going to go into the military
not anymore
you know and
the people that have historically been
enlisting in the military and dying
to the united states have sort of been
the white middle class something like 70
percent of all casualties in the middle
east were the white middle class now if
you're going to tell if you're going to
discourage them
from enlisting in the military because
those are exactly the same people that
don't want this curriculum change so
i'll be agnostic on what i think about
the curriculum change but i know that
many of these people who were those that
were enlisting and disproportionately
dying way disproportionately dying
in the mideast wars were these people
that don't want the curriculum change
i think they're called the silent
majority yeah
so um just like police departments
are having a really hard time recruiting
that retirements have gone through the
roof
you know i think is is it uh
governor uh
or mayor lightfoot
over there in chicago what a trainer
cutting the budget to now
you know begging people to to join
because of the crime changes again all
these things are the same issue viewed
from a different
facet of the prism
so
i guess my final question then
is
what's the fate of the us dollar it's
going down
the reason the u.s dollar has been the
world's sole reserve currency forever
has to do 100 years we're the biggest
economy
and we had rule of law that was
reliable which is less reliable now
and we had the biggest military by far
he who rules the seas so
well we do have we do have by far the
most battleships and carriers yes
but the um
chinese economy was projected to be
bigger in terms of gdp
years ago it's 2050 then it was brought
forward to 2040 then 2030 and i think
everybody now thinks it's before 2030.
and if the yuan keeps appreciating 2026
in terms of their gdp but their gdp is
real gdp
right it's production they they don't
have a deficit
on a perpetual basis they often have a
surplus and their infrastructure is not
crumbling yes of savings we don't have
savings their infrastructure is brand
new
so
their economy is going to bear united
states economy it probably already is
from a productive capacity
and they have made no bones about their
willingness and desire to have the
world's largest military most powerful
military and they have the money to do
it
so where are the china detractors wrong
there there there's a whole cohort of of
people in the investment community who
are so anti china's going down china is
going down i don't know if they're going
down i mean ultimately all empires go
down uh the roman empire fell apart and
one of one of the signposts
of an empire that's in jeopardy is they
start employing mercenaries
as their army which we haven't done
broadly but we did it in afghanistan
and mercenaries not surprisingly when it
comes time to actually battle
they're not they'll be a mercenary as
long as they're getting a check and they
feel safe right and we've paid them a
lot
once they think that the check is about
to dry up and the battle might be coming
suddenly
it's not that attractive anymore yep and
one of the other
major
contributors to the fall of
of rome was income inequality
sure
it wasn't it was massive at the time so
people used to be able to farm their own
land and then they couldn't anymore and
everything was absorbed by that top
layer of it and eventually it came back
to haunt them when the the uber rich
because of wealth inequality
come to a point where their army
isn't getting populated they take all of
their uber wealth and they pay
mercenaries
and we've started to do that so china is
going to have the biggest military
maybe not as soon as 2026 but the but
the biggest economy by 2030 for sure the
way things are going and it's more of a
real economy as i said right and then of
course one of the most reliable
long-term signposts for the direction of
the dollar is the twin deficit
when the twin deficit goes up the dollar
is going to go down
and when the twin deficit is under
control the dollar can can be firm or
stable well it's obvious that the twin
deficit is just beyond any historical
context
so
the budget deficit alone is truly 20 of
gdp
if we continue to do the stimulus it'll
stay there it was there for the 12
months ending say june 30th or so
20 of gdp
and then the the trade deficit which is
one of the reasons why i say the the
stimulus was good for china our trade
deficit is after years of
largely stability has gone up by a
couple of percentage points started to
widen again yep quickly so you add them
up and
uh the dollar
sort of seems sort of doomed uh given
the twin deficit situation
and the ascendance of china's military
and economic power so china
again has made no bones about the fact
that they want
a seat at the reserve currency table and
they're in a much better position what
would stop them if you have savings
biggest economy
and biggest military
why aren't you and internal productivity
why aren't you the the global reserve
currency so i think that's really
what we we talk about like i can't
believe you know wow every recession
gets worse than the recession before it
for the past multiple receptions ever
you know
um
every problem you know first you know
we we had a housing
bubble yep
right
and every solution has been non
non every solution we've thrown has been
in a non-productive manner so the gold
financial crisis
you know and then the tools keep being
pulled out so we we had to bail out
we had to bail out the auto companies
then we had to bail out the banks
and
and then we had to bail out the people
and then we sort of had to bail out
people and sort of the fed
yes sort of the fed and so
i don't know if we're you know i'm going
to bail out the next one i
i don't think so because i don't think
we can bail out the dollar right
and that's why i think it's the number
one
investment theme for true investors i'm
talking about
i'm not talking about people with the
report quarterly to institutional
clients and
you know
answer ridiculous micro questions i'm
talking about people that are investing
money for their retirement and they know
they're not going to really make many
changes
i think they should be i
one of the things that i did and felt
when you do something
when you change course on something that
you've been
steadfast in the same position
for like 10 years it feels really weird
to make that allocation sure it just it
just
uh foreign
and i bought european stocks sold
u.s stocks to buy european stocks and
one of my funds
because i i i really think you're going
to be better off on the currency trends
i'm talking about u.s dollars
investments plus their stock markets in
europe in particular have stopped
underperforming for over a year now
emerging markets are still really dicey
emerging markets are underperformed by a
lot and so if you look at u.s equity
performance versus the world it looks
really strong but it's only because of
emerging markets being weak
it's european stocks have matched us
stocks performance now
step up for step virtually with some day
by day volatility but
almost step up step by step for the for
over a year now
and so weirdly uh i i own european
activities which has a funny feeling
but it's not really working but it's not
not working
and i think ultimately ultimately that
that will uh that will work out on the
dollar translation and
as long as it's
not not working it's not even
uncomfortable would you own the yuan
no
i wouldn't i
i i'd be afraid of uh some sort of
author authoritarian confiscation
something yeah
i i it's kind of like i always say i
really don't want to buy
real estate a foreign country
one one that one that has a history of
bad actions
because you don't really own it
so um
we'll we'll wind this down i i did see
your props for charlie watts i have to
say that was great my favorite drummer
so and your observation that he made it
look seamless he made it look easy
simple yeah his drumming was
incredibly um
it was it was it had a spareness to it
uh
an essence and
he he had a weird style
it's where one of the things he did is
when we hit the snare drum
usually you'd play the snare drum it's a
high hat yep
he wouldn't he would not hit the high
heavy
he would do that a lot and it created a
breathing space
in his drumming and he was incredibly um
restrained on all the things
they would just be the
and not not all that flashy stuff
so i actually they were contempt
they hit the scene contemporaneously
another great drummer who's
really underrated is ringo starr
really underrated because he created
more
innovative rhythms and introductions and
licks you can tell from the the intro
drum thing
exactly what beatles song it is like she
loves you
yup that's true i never thought about
that
right but i was raised on the rolling
stones not the beatles so i liked i
loved them both well i mean what's not
to like about them both but but
yeah
i couldn't believe when i saw he was 80.
so
you know how could charlie watts outlive
keith richards i know i mean how
impossible is that i mean
physiologically that's just a modern
medical miracle i guess with all of that
he's sort of embalmed or something i
think he's had all these transfusions
and what have you
one more thing really quickly and then
i'll ask the final question ncaa playing
college college players
the supreme court allowing ncaa players
to get paid i mean where i am in texas
things are just going nuts teams are
going left right in between we're
changing conferences conferences are
blowing up
what do you think about this
i'm kind of in favor of it um i don't
have a strong opinion
about it that's not an issue that i
follow very closely but it seems to me
that
universities should not be allowed to
make billions of dollars or millions and
millions of dollars
off of
somebody else's work
um so
from that perspective i i'm sure we'll
have all kinds of ramifications or a
nation of free agency i mean
universities do all kinds of stuff you
know the they hire you know graduate
students
are kind of like forced labor mm-hmm
that's true they pay them almost nothing
right they put them into these
classrooms they teach them a
fraction of what a professor gets and so
you know it's funny people talk about
um the negatives through history of
of uh forced labor and slavery and all
that
but when you look at it it seems to me
that every single major power that was
dominant in their day
well a lot of them had forced labor and
slavery
and china sword has forced labor right
now
and even capitalism is is a cousin
of uh of of uh
of this
because what is capitalism you pay
people a certain amount of money
and they create for the company more
than they're being paid that's that's
just fundamentally has to be the premise
that isn't exactly forced labor
but it's not terribly far it's a cousin
yeah and so what people understand is
empires will always have
this characteristic
always what people don't understand is
that the germany when they when they
came to uh
lead into world war ii
you know one of their strategies world
war ii was basically take people over so
you can have forced labor right because
there's that's how you maximize your
product your productivity versus cost
is you exploit somebody
and uh
you know it's it's it's interesting
people are trained to
associate
attributes to to simply words
nomenclature when when you really look
at it
it's always this tension
and it will never go away
between
a company you know going to the top of
its field
and
sort of what they pay people right who
they're exploiting
so
it's it's you asked me what did i learn
first question from kovit
that was one of the things that i
figured out what i just talked about
well let's end this on a super super
high note all right
what are the bills going to do this year
i think the bills
will win the super bowl this year or
next year okay but this year that's the
kind of their window it's so hard in the
nfl to keep your team together wait
isn't the super bowl where's the super
bowl in
i think i think it's here here or else
it's vegas one year i think 2022 it's so
far so far yeah maybe it's 2023 it's in
vegas either way it's nearby right true
so i i'm certain the bills will go to
the super bowl this year next year i
would put the probability of 80 percent
so i shouldn't say certain
but uh they have their quarterback keeps
getting better and the thing about the
bills
is players want to play there
which is a really big change it's that's
that's really the that's half your
battle it's a really big piece of making
it to the top
because for years when you're a loser
you don't make the playoffs for 17 years
in a row he'll go i was drafted by
buffalo yeah yeah oh god you know
but not only
people love playing there because the
cost of living is still relatively low
buffalo is one of america's
most successful cities right now
it's incredible what's going on it's all
has to do with the fact that it was in
such a bad place
that uh well put this it was in such a
great place in 1900 richest city per
capita in the country
which creates tremendous building with
tremendous architecture then it went
downhill for for decades
and they didn't have enough money to
tear them down
by all rights a lot of these old
buildings should have been torn down
there was something called the
continental building which was vacant
for decades and i know the guy that
bought it
and he bought it for basically zero
and he put the money into it it's now a
very high-end boutique hotel and there's
tons of this stuff going on so the city
is vibrant it's there's people coming in
and uh now the team's winning and the
fans well everybody knows about the
bills fans yeah they're just they're
just crazy i i don't like going to games
there people are so so
you know
so all that's going on uh and so that's
a really big positive and the players
people can't understand buffalo is a
very very small place everybody knows
everybody
uh
everybody everybody has largely the same
experience
um in l.a people people that live in the
valley of a totally different experience
people live in the south bay
but it's not like that so i'm a huge uh
bills fan and i suffered all the way
through all those years and i think
they're finally going to win it right it
really comes down to for this year
and the
the whole thing turns on their defensive
line
did they make moves that will get a pass
rush going because that was that was
kind of their achilles heel they didn't
they were giving the quarterbacks too
much time as we saw in the super bowl
the the
tampa bay just had a pass rush
and mahomes was just flummoxed he didn't
know what to do because
he didn't have enough time and the pass
rush was so relentless i was actually at
the super bowl the bills went to the afc
championship and just in case they went
to the super well i would make sure i
had a ticket because i was going to be
curtailed uh availability of seats
and i figured i could sell it if the
bills don't make it well the bills
didn't make it they actually got beaten
pretty pretty thoroughly in the fc
championship game and um
i couldn't sell i could i it was just
the price just didn't go up
in fact it was going down which really
surprised me i thought if tampa bay is
there there'd be demand right
but i so i ended up saying well what the
hell we'll make lemonade out of lemons
and we went to the super bowl and i
gotta tell you it was great because a
i didn't care who won
which helps out a lot oh yeah because
you feel like you're you know i feel
like you're getting indigestion when
your team always seems like you know
your team's underperforming even if
they're hanging on to a lead so i didn't
care who won so i was
able to completely analyze the game and
i loved doing that
and there were no la it was it was a zoo
getting in because the
infrastructure getting to that stadium
isn't very good
uh but once you were inside
there was no lines because they had all
the concessions were open it was great
uh it didn't like having to wear an n15
was in a 95 and 95 yeah
but it would not matter that much and uh
so i had a really good time but
the the uh the next time i hope the
bills will be there okay well we'll meet
up in buffalo next time after after
buffalo is victorious what you're gonna
see have you ever been to buffalo first
time it will be my first time i'll tell
you what i'll tell you the way it goes
people go to buffalo and they without
exception report back
i couldn't believe how good it was and
i'll tell you why because the
expectations are so low
[Laughter]
on that note
looking forward to buffalo
go bills go bills and thank you for your
time thanks then
appreciate it well i hope you enjoyed
jeffrey unlacked the sequel i know i
enjoyed getting in another great visit
with him
my second excuse to come out to
california in the last few years so
happy to be here
if you didn't happen to catch the
inaugural down the middle the first
interview with jeffrey go back take the
time
watch it you'll enjoy it and then watch
this one next
you'll enjoy both equally i will see you
next time for down the middle with dean
martino booth thank you for being here
[Music]